the Harbor Town of Casa machola teme has
been transformed and disfigured instead
of Hosting motor yachts and fishing
boats the once picturesque Waterfront is
now a tangle of overturned cars ripped
up trees and half-buried passenger buses
and a thick layer of mud
Coast Guard divers are searching the
harbor for bodies several people are
still missing and the fear is they may
have been swept to their deaths
residents try to pick their way through
the wreckage in the silt and grief is
rapidly turning to anger
it is the fault of our old politicians
who did not do preventative work on the
mountains they cut down the trees and
this is the result it happened before in
2010 when a 15 year old girl died this
time it was a catastrophe other
residents blame a combination of Nature
and negligence torrential rain and the
steep hills above the town delivered a
deluge of surface water and then the
hillside itself gave way sending
Boulders trees mud and debris barreling
down the slopes smashing anything in its
path
we were at home and woke up my husband
woke up and went outside and there was a
waterfall of water and mud coming down I
called my brother we went down the
street to get to the car park but we
couldn't because it was already flooded
with mud at his Sunday address in the
Vatican Pope Francis spoke of his
solidarity and sorrow for the victims
and offered his prayers and the Italian
government has declared a state of
emergency for iskia a decision which
means ministers can start to release
around 2 million dollars in relief funds
the island has experienced earthquake's
volcanic eruptions and severe weather
before an earthquake in 2017 left two
people dead the final total from this
tragedy is likely to be higher Paul
Brennan Al Jazeera